[Music]
a gross weight and welcome everyone to a
great backyard garden with me
Michel junus waist thank you for those
of you who have congratulated me on
becoming the chairman of the collar
village council thank you very very much
if you watch in Perm to choose the video
you would have seen that I uploaded a
video where someone sent me a video to
react to and I reacted to where someone
actually wear nifty odd does I believe
they took bottles and they cut off the
top of the bottle so what they did they
took bottles I cut off the top of one
bottle they drilled a hole in the cover
of another and let's imagine that is not
here and they put it in this like that
we for Fred or string or rope come out
from this bottle of water going up to
this model to be plants this was a self
watering technique and I thought it was
very very innovative and I thought to
myself perhaps I can do this but in a
different way let me just tell you why
this happens or why this can work
whether you use the water the rope up or
down the things that once there's a way
for water to travel or to go through it
will pass when you have the soil on top
it will dry out
eventually I plan to take up the
moisture or Sun or point is it a gel on
top and there's water below and there's
a medium a way for the waters to work
now water will move from an area of high
concentration to low concentration as
long as there's a way for it to go
through so even if we population this
technique kurosu without the work
evaporation will happen and water will
go up rise even if the water do not rise
because of the whoop do because this is
filled water and the top will be drying
out constantly because the plants be
taken in moisture
now water will move from the high
concentration up the rope to the low
concentration and this is how to work
and simply happening with this technique
so I'm just gonna show you exactly what
I did I'll show you the result because
it did work and I will tell you more
about it
let's go ahead I fill this up of water
and then I use a cotton cloth or batsto
wheel drive a lot of cotton I think this
is mini cotton I roll it up and then I
put piece another soil here and then
this part here now what happened is
because what I'll move from an area of
high concentration to low concentration
as I told you meaning there is extremely
wet moist and that was dry so the water
came up
dry cloth when done the dry cloth and
will work faster because of gravity and
went in here now as you can see this
part is dry and this part is wet so this
goes to show that the water is moving
constantly from an area of high
concentration down the cloth which is
like a medium this is what it used to go
down or what I was doing I had a stick
on the hill hold on because what
happened is a limb just see if I can
find a way right I had to use this stick
to keep the cloth off of the peel
because similar to domina the water was
going on on sub-wavelength is going in
the instead right so this is an idea I
can walk off pretty well I'm quite sure
just by watching that you might because
for me to be in the Old Market Garden I
let me just show you already a tomato
here right here started to sprout so as
you can see this dry let's your idea is
now if you notice the top is dry but the
bottom is wet what has happen is that
the water is slowly moving from an area
of higher concentration which is here to
lower concentration obviously to start
from the bottom and adventure the top
will become the top here which is dry
will eventually look like this here
which is moist but this idea can work
pretty well as I told you I saw this on
even to Tuesday when I reacted to the
video and I thought to myself I can try
this or know what I'm going to do I'm
going to try it out in my plan to stand
right here I'm gonna try it out right
here so I'm gonna try to find a way to
put in a pail of water here I'm on the
next end over there and then have a
cloth right here lying down or maybe I
might put it from here to here so that
the water and coming from the peel up
here come down on here and I have
another peels over here so this area
because the moist and obviously like I
will put the cloth to pass between hand
here so no matter what moisture mantle
good I could to the plant but because
they'll be moist the water be passing so
this is an idea I think that can pretty
well and it's very comical because you
can feel a continent water and you don't
need to come and watch it every two days
or three days if you have enough if you
have a big enough peel either to only
this lasted about what three to four
days and it's extremely hot in the green
ah so I think we should also take into
consideration that evaporation
been happening but it's not as constant
of course because we can see that it
worked if that was dry then we can say
okay the water here disappeared from
evaporation in the atmosphere but here
is extremely moist its moist it's more
sense working so I wanna encourage you
of course obviously there isn't too long
and I'm talking too much
but please be encouraged that you should
try out this idea find a way with your
bucket garden to try this idea and being
innovative be very creative in using out
this idea because of course guys I hope
that you enjoy this video feature thank
you very much for requesting that I
reacted to the video that I didn't
choose the easier the video that you
want me to react to don't forget you
could leave a comment below on any other
videos of adversity bucket garden or
could send me a message by whatsapp
number one seven six seven six one seven
zero two two four don't forget to check
out my other youtube channel which is
called genus with just a comment tree I
will post a link middle of course guys
thank you for subscribing to our YouTube
channel and don't forget when you press
subscribe there's a bear next to will
subscribe click on it so that you'll be
notified when I put a new video and I
wish it back in Canon thank you for
liking our Facebook page thank you
follow us on Twitter and on Instagram
and to encourage you to remember a
backyard garden in some way so
definitely keep the doctors away and
address ways out